speaking of good rulings from judges not
on the covid front but on the
presidential race a georgia judge
has approved a forensic examination of
the voting machines
so there have been questions about these
voting machines
the theories about what could have
happened go all the way up to the level
that there's some international
conspiracy and the votes were changed
but some of the theories are also more
modest just that there were individual
issues with these voting machines
and those individual issues would be
enough to change possibly the election
in a state so for so long the media have
been saying no this is ridiculous no
there could be no problems with
electronic voting
no there's no way that they're connected
to the internet even though they
probably are connected to the internet
no it's not a big deal move on move on
certify the election well this judge
district judge timothy batten senior
issued the order
saying no do not reset the dominion
election systems
do not wipe the machines we need to have
a forensic audit now what's going on
in the counting process in the
recounting process well
georgia also now has to rescan 12 000
ballots
the georgia republican party chairman
david shafer said on wednesday night
fulton county is going to rescan
a whole 12 000 batch of ballots
because of quote unexplained technical
problems
unexplained technical problems uh fulton
county commissioner liz houseman
alerted david that fulton county is
redoing this this count republican
monitors have then been
sent out to the tabulation center but
david shaffer
in in the gop of georgia has been
sounding the alarm on this
for a month now or more
there were legitimate concerns
over fraud there is a lot of evidence
that there was fraud
in georgia twelve thousand votes being
reskinned what's the margin in georgia
right now separating biden
and trump twelve thousand
yikes that's not good do we have any
other evidence of fraud yes we do some
video footage from the election centers
came out yesterday
fulton county sent the poll watchers
home
at 10 30 p.m on election night they said
sorry you got to get out of here we're
going to stop counting now so anyone
trying to make sure we don't
mess around with the ballots go home the
republican officials
the poll watchers generally go home
but a smaller group of election
officials stuck around
the counting center and they didn't just
stick around for 10 minutes and get
their coats they stuck around for hours
they stuck around for a minimum of two
hours we have this
on video they tabulated 3 000
ballots per hour per
voting machine and there were multiple
voting machines you can see people going
out underneath tables
wheeling out boxes ballots after we were
told
they were going to stop counting after
the poll watchers went home
this sort of thing is the fraud i'm not
saying it's even enough fraud to swing
the vote
maybe it is maybe it isn't sure stinks
to high heaven
but the mere act of doing this is the
fraud
huge questions in georgia 12 000 votes
separate the race
you got 3 000 votes per hour per machine
and multiple machines in just this one
place
goodness gracious how are we supposed to
have faith in our election system
especially in georgia which you may
recall i
figured it was on this show or in
another interview i did express
fears that there would be these kinds of
shenanigans in georgia
specifically in georgia before the
election
all of that means there is absolutely no
reason whatsoever
to concede the presidential race before
the legal process plays out not one